[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh did
I interrupt you brooding just now times
have changed you need to change with
them we have to be tough and
battle-ready
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh hey it's Kane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
[Music]
save your life
I don't get it we'll help me rescue my
friends go anywhere near that sistar
system it's ruled by an alien coin only
the toughest you're gonna get out of
there alive
I'm a queen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I could
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable hey guys
he'll go back don't worst was much more
palatable double dots on your face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't welcome to rhyme city a
celebration of the harmony between
humans and pokémon Tim your tart was a
legend in this precinct
if you were anything like your tanner
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they try to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right guys adorable you're
adorable they can't understand me kiss
you no one else here
I don't need a Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
magic that brought us together and that
magic is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah so tell us what we want to
know pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch
you're from oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
yeah you see the new movie trailer for
what you ain't see what what is it Bucky
what they're making another Toy Story
movie now I thought those movies would
dawn dog they made three movies Tim make
three movies this is number four toy
stories - yeah what about Buzz Lightyear
stuff I am Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger
what is like to infinity and your mom
that's not right you sure no that's not
right I'm pretty sure that's it let me
show you to insanity and blonde what do
you even say guys you got it all wrong
it's to infinity and beyond go to
infinity dummies it's impossible nothing
about science
[Music]
it's time to open the park Wonderland is
now open
I like it when the ideas come from you
that's that I'm talking about operation
looky-loo is it go honey have you seen
my cell phone where did your model go I
don't play that anymore
seriously
[Music]
welcome to the mark have a nice day how
is this possible hello my name is Steve
I know who you are you know who we are
my mom and I invented this place and
somehow you came to life
we're alive what happened here the
darkness happened it brought an army of
chimpanzees but sorry naughty it's time
to bring the park back to light
who's with me Oh with you oh no he's
allergic to pollen Terry
[Music]
such a woman those come-hither tusks Oh
[Music]
well that didn't work out at least we
got dinner
in Fiji every manager at our company has
a college degree the only thing stopping
you is you
[Music]
do you ever look at your life wonder how
you got there if you make different
choices would you be happy Arthur got
his MBA from Duke it's the best man for
the job
no sir I am I just wish we lived in a
world where street smarts equal book
smarts school Oh the educated people in
their fancy houses name their kids after
fruit and climb Kilimanjaro somebody
call for you there's something about a
job interview oh my god Franklin and
Clark a resume interests me Wharton
Business School I'm sorry what
and of course you have got to see her
Facebook page my facebook page Obama I
gave you a completely new identity you
said you wanted to be fancy so I just
like Cinderella Jurassic well I got you
in the door you've got the job baby you
should shame let's go who's the cheat on
the tail you're the you're the champ
it's not easy getting a job for a woman
your age Oh watch me imma be on okay we
need to wear anything other than that
you look like mrs. Doubtfire wow this is
my office
they gave you an apartment already cards
I'm gonna take these walk your hands
don't you dare I'm gonna take these
coasters you're gonna come clean right
[Music]
Maya Vargas these are my friends from
Norton Warren we did some time in the
Peace Corps together we save whales so
confuses Facebook thing with we you
really are
I admire you kind of who I want to be
when I grow up
you were always fit enough you have u11
that every dollar we're looking at the
new Chinese distributors the only
employee we have who speaks Mandarin for
me I got an idea
our cats veterinarian speak slander we
would love to schedule a tour for you
but we have to wait for the deal to be
closed but right at our feet Oh
Yoji suddenly gone mom she identity scan
initiated
hello agent sterling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it worked
subject appears disoriented Walter what
did you do everywhere nobody notices
them it's the most perfect form of Spica
taste unburden eat right now stop girl
seriously hey Lance look at me
look at you I can't not look at you
Walter I can see my butt and your face
at the same time
[Music]
give me a lucky lotto and I CR would you
sure you don't still ask you do know
that's too bad
I write poetry like that son who dogs
from another dimension
[Music]
what is wrong with you
[Music]
wife's from the oh I'm gonna suck the
nectar out of it till the wheels come
off always remember the universe has a
way of leading you to where you're
supposed to be at the moment you're
supposed to be there let's do this took
me 20 years to find you
you can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes be perfect for this job you
really think a black suit is going to
solve all your problems
no but it's damn good on you we are
[Music]
recognizable only as DejaVu and
dismissed just as quickly time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to my beat
you will be with agent peach one of the
best ever to weather suit
[Music]
catching up from a daily meditation time
for lunch ah thank you hungry it's 9:30
it's Tuesday's taco day we've been
compromised
Oprah's every citizen of this planet at
risk
[Applause]
you could all just look right here just
try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like the tables of time I was
incredible
it's just a movie you see Natalie's lots
not a fairytale girls like us don't get
that all I look in the mirror doll when
though Julia Roberts
every day day swipe my father mommy
Natalie saying that romantic comedies
are about all those maybes Eliza -
terrible pop songs I think people would
have an easier time seeing you if you
were a little more open I'm done you're
in your mercy sir this is an emergency
room this is at williams-sonoma
them away downtown it looks like
somebody's what a beauty filter across
New York City and I win one what's your
emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace it
all with much nicer stuff so your
emergency is that your apartment is too
big and you have every shoe you could
ever want
yeah exactly that's what I yeah you get
mad you go crazy I hit my head really
hard and I woke up in this alternate
universe and now I have a gay sidekick
who's sitting gay rights back like 100
years of love working the legs and guys
look me in the eyes you're caught
beguiling aren't you are you feeling
what I'm feeling
No
I'm trapped economy
[Applause]
okay boots what's the update I have to
get a man to fall in love again I'm Josh
[Music]
last night was amazing I think we
actually did anything it just cut to the
next morning well just get back here
okay last night was amazing
Natalie I love
[Music]